На українських дорогах хронічно
перевищують швидкість і грубо ігнорують правила дорожнього руху.
А після недавньої ДТП
у Харкові, внаслідок якої загинули шестеро людей,
багато українських ЗМІ почали
писати, що Україна - ще й лідер за смертністю на дорогах
серед європейських країн.
За кількістю загиблих на мільйон населення
у 2016 році серед країн ЄС
найгірші справи були у Болгарії.
Тут в автокатастрофах гине щороку близько
семиста людей на 7 мільйонів населення.
Офіційно показник смертності - 99.
Схожа статистика у Румунії та Латвії.
Щодо України таких даних у "Євростаті" немає.
Водночас неважко зробити власний підрахунок.
Співвідношення офіційної кількості
загиблих на українських дорогах за 2016 рік
до чисельності населення -
видає показник 94. Кращий, ніж у Болгарії
за цей же період.
Якщо порівнювати абсолютні цифри, то минулого року
в ДТП в Україні загинули, за даними МВС,
більше 4 тисяч людей.
Зокрема півтори тисячі пішоходів.
У сусідній Росії, лише за російськими офіційними даними, дорожні інциденти
забирають більше 20 тисяч життів щороку –
майже як в усьомУ Євросоюзі. Російський показник смертності
від ДТП - 143 на мільйон населення.
Гірше за Україну цей фактор і у Грузії,
і у країнах Середньої Азії.
Є третій вимір. Співвідношення
між смертністю та кількістю автомобілів.
В Україні, за міжнародними експертними оцінками,
понад 14 мільйонів транспортних засобів. У Німеччині -
52 мільйони. При цьому в ФРН в 2016 році
загинули в ДТП
3 тисячі двісті людей. В Україні ситуація за цим показником
у п’ять разів гірша.
В Україні смертність від дорожніх інцидентів на душу населення
не найвища, а лише одна з найвищих у Європі.
Україна - на рівні Болгарії, Румунії та Латвії.
Водночас за абсолютною кількістю загиблих у ДТП
Україна справді випереджає будь-яку країну ЄС.
Гірші справи лише у Росії.